sur le camion kaki pracc temps le
catafalque impasse à face étonnant ce
matin dans les rues de tel plus tard
entre des petites soeurs des
missionnaires de la charité et les
soldats de l'armée indienne
des funérailles nationales en effet pour
la somme des pôles
dans l'ensemble du stade mais hadji
toutes les religions sont représentées
pour la célébration de cette cérémonie
funèbre en testant hindous musulmans
sikhs ou bouddhistes unis dans un même
hommage à la religieuse catholique que
l'archevêque de canterbury qualifiera
danse de la paix règne président épouses
des chefs d'état il y assister à ses
obsèques du prix nobel de la paix qui a
consacré sa vie comme le rappellera un
lépreux aux damnés de la terre
la france était représentée par
bernadette chirac et bernard kouchner
les états unis par hillary clinton
[Musique]
le représentant du pape le cardinal
angelo sodano a lu un hommage de jean
paul ii à la plus chère des pauvres qui
a allumé dans selon jessie une place
d'un mur offrant des déshérités une
orpheline un lépreux et un aveugle à
leur madone de calcutta soeur nirmala
qui a pris la succession de mère teresa
à la tête des missionnaires de la
charité a demandé à l'assemblée de prier
pour que l'ordre garde la même
détermination dans son combat pour les
pauvres
[Musique]
mon action n'est qu'une goutte d'eau
dans l'océan disait mère teresa mais ce
sont les gouttes d'eau qui forment un
océan dépôt de couronnes au nom de la
france par bernadette chirac et bernard
kouchner au pied du cercueil blanc
recouvert du drapeau indien
safran blanc et vert autre image
surprenante de ses obsèques
les religieuses qui accompagne mère
teresa jusqu'à sa dernière demeure
au son de la cornemuse c'est à
l'intérieur de la maison de la mer comme
on surnomme le siège de la congrégation
des missionnaires de la charité que mère
teresa a été inhumé des soldats d'élite
de l'armée indienne lui ont rendu les
honneurs charge quatre salles de 32
coupe-feu 4 clairon ou ensuite sonné
l'adieu aux armes marquant la fin de
cette cérémonie